pan sanitizer is for [ __ ] but i'll
say that to the day i die i put covert
in my tea in the morning
so this is a brand new guy we've
actually never watched him before he's
pretty funny made five mellow eighteen
well generated five million dollars
eighteen years old thank you he's
actually also from boston oh [ __ ] and we
don't know him no we don't know um
he's dashing handsome people compare him
to entertain a lot it's weird maybe not
in the best way
he gets a lot of hate comments pretty
hilarious good guy though
he sounds like a douche right
might be part dude looks like it might
be part running a country it's like it
genuinely makes me sad chad i can tell
that this guy is probably a crypto nerd
probably like a young entrepreneur
conservative guy who wants to get into
content creation but i can hear in his
voice this kid gets money that's funny
am i right are you like uh this dude you
make money right i could hear the ben
shapiro money conservative jordan
peterson in your voice
yeah you hit the nail on the head i'm a
crypto crypto guy that made a lot of
money
got it and so now you want to get into
the content creation yeah so i've always
kind of been into content creation but i
just parted ways from my company so now
my full focus has been on content and
that's why i've been you know popping up
surprise it's me oh my god so yeah now
you've been compared to ben shapiro
andrew tate i like these comparisons
and greg from diary of a wimpy kid and
for those of you guys that don't know we
just made a podcast with sneako so i'll
drop the link in the description for
that it's pretty fun though though we
got sneaker on a pod i still think he's
such a pumpkin he's a pumpkin i do he's
just sweet look at his face i love
sneaker i know what a cutie pie i'm a
fan snake pumpkin he's all full of [ __ ]
on these i'm a pumpkin bro i always [ __ ]
it up with girls in the funniest ways
dude the last time i was talking to this
girl we were sitting around a bonfire
for like two hours and she was sitting
on my lap in like this lawn chair
and after after two hours when she
finally gets up i go oh my god i feel
like flat stanley
yeah i know we did we didn't we didn't
talk again after that
yeah not my proudest moment and not my
brightest i wish i could think of i
think that's hereditary because i wish i
could think of
i'm sure it's something right outside
stupid ways i've said i've said so many
stupid things to guys that i look at my
i've had so many in put my foot in my
mouth kinds of things oh there's a
couple more of these coming up hilarious
i think that's hilarious yeah was she um
a big big girl no she was beautiful d1
soccer player good girl just sit in my
lap for a long time and when she got up
it felt like flat stanley pantizer is
for [ __ ] but i'll say that to the day
i die if you're afraid of some germs and
not toughening up your immune system
you're a [ __ ] and you deserve to get
sick i kind of agree with you so
you know my clients and good friends uh
retired navy seal tom shay yeah you know
you know you've met him he's absolutely
the coolest thing i mean one of the
funniest things he ever said we were
talking it was in the middle of covid we
were talking about him you know making
an appearance for a speaking engagement
somewhere and i was like you know are
you concerned about you know the
pandemic and he was like i put covert in
my tea in the morning
those guys are tough as nails tough as
nails i mean those guys they have you
don't see them using hand sanitizer
after every little thing no if they ran
out of food or water
in his book uh his first book
unbreakable he talks about the scene
where all the navy seals just found this
barrel full of random liquid and they
drank it because it was either that or
dehydrated to death you know so yeah
they're they're sick [ __ ] those guys
are nuts yeah and you know what do you
remember the time when you baby you were
like a year and a half and when i would
go shopping i would you know you would
get out of the carriage and walk around
and we were in costco and i i turned her
i couldn't find i didn't see you in
front of me and i turned around and you
were behind me and you were bent over
and you were licking the floor and i
just saw in that moment i've been
anti-hand sanitizer since day one this
is nothing new this is nothing new yeah
it's nothing new since before you even
understood it you were like uh yeah you
were you were building that immune
system right from day one i wrote this
down on the worst day of 2021 for me my
friends absolutely [ __ ] me over and
you know what rather than sitting there
and bitching i took a piece of paper and
i wrote down everything that i wanted to
do in that year retire my mother make
those kids eat [ __ ] prove everyone wrong
make six figures be able to be generous
to my parents and people i care about
and you know what happened i would read
it in the mirror every single day and at
the end of the year it all became true i
remember that day i remember you came in
my room and we sat down and we talked
and you were upset and you were hurt you
were you felt betrayed and uh like every
other time you had a hard time when you
were a kid i was like this too shall
pass i know it's hard right now but
you're gonna look back on this and
you're gonna be grateful that it
happened because they're gonna be better
things because you're put on the path
you're meant to be on i think you had
seen it happen so many times just in
your life in my life and i always made
sure to talk about those things with you
that you you believed me in that moment
you know because you you saw it happen
so i it and i think that's what gave you
the strength to just be like you know
what yeah yeah i'm going to use this and
i'm going to go i didn't know i didn't i
didn't waste any time like i already
talked about i haven't told the whole
story in the video it'll probably be a
little bit before i talk about it yeah
yeah i mean it's tough to talk about not
because it's emotional but because it's
just you know
bringing drama to the internet bringing
drama you know talking [ __ ] about other
people that i have nothing like against
the guys now like if they're watching
like i'm still friends with both of them
and i hope they don't take you know they
don't take this the wrong way but i'm
gonna talk about it like this is a
pivotal point in my life so and it
helped form the success and what i've
become today it puts you on the path
where you're supposed to be and you know
like some girl breaks your heart
somebody somebody dumps you something
you know you don't get the job you
wanted you don't get the you know the
spot on the team you know what that just
means that there's something else for
you out there that's meant for you you
got to go out and get it stop posting
your [ __ ] goals on social media
nobody cares not only that but every
time you do it it lets off happy
chemicals in your brain which ultimately
hurts you from actually achieving those
goals instead write them down at a
notebook and read it in the mirror every
single day until it becomes true and
then flex on those
you know it's true i feel like every
time i talk about something that's
happening or i want to happen if i talk
about it too much they say talk about it
tell everybody because it manifests it
but you know what in a way it it doesn't
and then if it doesn't happen no then
you then you look like an app then you
look like an ass and you know what find
somebody in your world to talk about it
with because i think you and i talking
about things privately like that we
really want to accomplish is valuable
because then we can support each other
but the whole internet doesn't need to
know i don't need you know julie from
second grade going you go girl i don't
care which you know really we know yeah
since i left my company my full focus
has been on content and this and this is
why you have been seeing me so much
lately because i'm a marketer and my
full focus now is on myself and building
my brand as much as possible and your
mom and my mom well yeah she's the
famous one here well so a couple months
ago me and my friends were back there
you know matt nolan smoking a jay what
are you going to do so we're out there
hanging out and i'm i'm telling them
this this is just yeah well i hope their
mother see you this is just after what
are you gonna do this is just after i
leave the company and i'm telling them
this entire content takeover plan i'm
saying how i'm going to start making
videos like these saying crazy topics
basically what tate did and then build
my online university have affiliates
reposting my stuff so i just conquer and
it's pretty crazy seeing it all come
into fruition now because they literally
heard me saying this when i didn't have
as like even close to as much of a right
it was just
it was just still in it but i don't post
it on social media like about to take
over get ready like no i just started
posting and i started grinding and
people see the results obviously here
the cigar and gone by it's a little
extra but it's a lot extra and but you
know what i gotta say you know if you
once you if you've ever met a famous
person or even somebody who is an actor
right in a in a local theater company if
you only saw them on stage you would
think of them as their character that
they're playing and not uh you know
they're very different from the kitchen
table i'm not saying you're playing a
character here because that is not
really the full analogy but what i'm
saying is you know you're you're having
a good time here you know yeah you're
being a little extra we're having fun
with this but you're i actually am the
same person at the kitchen table you're
actually much quieter and you're you
know you're my pumpkin minions movie
made 1.2 billion dollars this year off
of tick tock marketing alone i myself
have generated over five million dollars
with no marketing budget just utilizing
tick tock if you aren't trying to learn
the strategies of how to use social
media to your advantage with no
marketing budget i don't even know what
the [ __ ] you're doing anymore and you
better hurry up because the russians and
the chinese are going to take over and
shut everything down they're going to
shut our grids down and then what are
you going to do you better already have
money in the bank
no you already better have money hiding
in the walls because shit's gonna get
ugly get on it now this is the time you
can go viral in days oh and just for the
record don't be mean to russians and
chinese people here in america that's
not what i'm saying this is a political
political commentary not a racial
commentary i don't want to hear it i'm
giving a shout out to my boy vlad he
started the sunny faz underscore clips
account not even a week ago this account
it's a week old on tick tock and it's at
over i think it's at almost 10 million
views and 1.1 million likes in a week on
tick tock a week on a brand new account
and that's what you can do imagine
you're doing that for yourself lad
that's like one of my favorite names too
that's cool he's a cool kid yeah i just
met him like last week but like you guys
can all do this this is nothing crazy
tick-tock is so easy it's crazy i have
some free tips in my discord if you guys
want to get started and then my full
university drops next month get started
what the hell do you have to lose the
free discord if you're on tick tock like
if you're on your phone goofing off
might as well be making money
that's a sneak oh like you're on your
phone you might as well be making money
when i was still in college i had a rule
with myself where i would only go out
once for every thousand dollars i made
pretty soon i was raking in thousands a
week then i made a rule with myself
where i wouldn't drink or smoke until i
hit six figures and i hit that goal
within two months i don't smoke
regardless so don't worry about that one
you just said you smoke hot on my back
deck
i'm in a pickle here with people whose
diapers i changed oh my god
thoughts
i like the i like the um that's right i
i like the rules you set for yourself
that's a real thing i mean i did that
and my first semester of college and
then i got into nfts and that [ __ ] and
kind of just went oh wow on that yeah
you know what i saw uh and then it just
consumed my life i saw a comment
somewhere on one of your social medias
where some someone was like i'm not
listening to you you're driving a you
know whatever
model a base model based model audi and
you were like uh yeah cause i'm not to
spend all my money on a ridiculous car
yes he could have bought a lamborghini
but then he would have no more money
like you have to be you know you're i
like that you
are really practical also you could have
had a lamborghini but you were smart and
and i really appreciate that about you
the worst thing about being an
entrepreneur working for myself is i
have to work with people in different
time zones so there'll be times where i
have to take business calls at 2 am and
sometimes i'm out at the bar and i'm
[ __ ] hammered taking business calls
all right well not for nothing but don't
get hammered get a little buzz you got
to be able to make a decent business
deal while i was in college you know i'm
enjoying college and this isn't like
where i have a scheduled business call
i'm not like i'm going to go get [ __ ]
wrecked and then take this call like
whatever you don't take the call and
something would come up no you have to
sometimes like i was running a company i
sometimes you gotta call your partner
and deal with some [ __ ] i'll be drunk
i'm like yeah sorry dude i was out i was
getting [ __ ] i've been telling you
for years keep your wits about you so
you know what's going on and that and
i'm thinking because you know people are
going to try to hurt you but you know
you could be hurting yourself if you get
a business call and you're incoherent i
don't get incoherently drunk you know
you've never seen me that drunk i
haven't thank cause i don't feel like
i'm drunk you know you're saying you
haven't you know i'm a pretty good drunk
the most unhealthy [ __ ] you can do when
you're young is to look at stuff like oh
i'm only 16. i have two years until i'm
18. i don't need to worry when you
should be looking at it like oh i'm 16.
if i grind my [ __ ] balls off the next
two years i can be so far ahead of
everyone else when i'm 18.
grind my [ __ ] balls off whatever your
goal is you want to be the best uh you
know fortnite player you want to be the
best hockey player you want to be the
best uh tick-tock entrepreneur yes grind
a little grind a little it's gonna or
more than a little but you know he's a
little he's a little harder than me you
know don't look at your age like an
excuse to be jacking off and that goes
for anybody older too because i i have
so many friends who are very talented
and they'll say oh you know i really
could have been a sports caster that
would i really would have loved to have
done that and i'm like you're not dead
yet you actually are really good at that
and the whole family thinks she'd be
really good at that nobody knows more
[ __ ] about sports than you and you've
got a great personality well no i'm too
old you know what you want to think that
that's your problem then you can just
stay where you are but don't actually if
you really want to think about it it is
not your age it's your attitude so i
don't care how young or how old you are
get to it when i was still talking to
this girl in miami we were driving in my
car and i was playing the kid leroy and
this broad starts busting my balls why
are you only playing sad music play like
some pitbull over the weekend do you
know what i did i blocked her a little
dramatic but you got to do what you got
to do hey you know bye felicia bye
felicia that's obviously a little bit of
a joke i didn't block her strictly
because of that there's multiple reasons
but literally
if you if you watch this video with half
a brain you'd be like yeah he probably
didn't just throw her on the side of the
road and kick her out but that did annoy
me i was like you're in my car i'm
playing my [ __ ] music this song just
came out and it's a banger who's tossed
her out like ken and you're gonna you're
gonna tell me what to put on and she
said put on some like non-sad music and
then she said the weekend gee that's
like the saddest music around what are
you talking about i don't know any of
the music you're talking about so you
love the kid the right now no i look
crispy d crispy d is [ __ ] amazing no
honestly that's like the he's that's my
outro guy by the way he's here he's the
outro music and so sonny and i were
driving to a wedding it was like five
hours and he was a dj i was the driver
most of the time
and uh i kept having to go
can you please just play play something
from just the 40 years that of music
that i know right and he so he would and
every now and then he would play a new
song that i would be like oh that's cool
this is all right
and then he played chris bd and i was
like i really like this this this is
awesome uh who's this and i thought he
was gonna say it was like a big star and
it wasn't no it's chris bd that's my boy
yeah he's gonna he's coming over for
dinner soon i invited him well you
better hurry up because we're moving to
florida so i i truly believe in that kid
yeah no i i have full faith in him i um
dm'd him a while ago when i didn't have
as much of a following at all and he was
super nice not a lot of artists would
reach back out to you and we've just
been talking ever since i've actually
talked to him since before i even made
six figures but he's seen my whole
journey it's kind of a dope thing listen
and you're seeing his journey this kid's
gonna just i know my deal is i'm helping
him market and stuff so that when he's
at the garden i get to like perform a
song with him that's the deal you can't
sing i move like a snake bam one million
dollars generated in one month what is
this kid sonny up to bam another four
million dollars generated over three
more months what the [ __ ] i thought this
kid was playing fortnite all day bam
this kid funnies all over my tick tock
feed i don't tell people my goals i do
the actions and let it speak for
themselves why in god's name are you
parked in a handicapped spot you were
raised better than that okay that's all
i saw or heard cause i'm young g no i
only park in handicap spots
see that's where the satire is like so
obvious where i'm trying to get under
people's skin like i'm doing to you
right now you park in a handicap spot
for 10 minutes and you make a couple
videos people like what what
my grandma might need to park there shut
up i only park in handicap spots did i
you must know about um so when i when i
turned 17 my parents bought me a car and
it was amazing and but it was too big
and i hated it because it was so too
hard to handle and they wanted like this
big boat for me so that i could you know
be safe but i couldn't handle it so uh
then they then they got me another car
and uh i went and hung out at a bar and
left my keys on the back of my chair and
the jacket and uh that car got stolen
and uh so you got i didn't know you you
got a car stolen yeah that's a whole
other story we can do it another time
but really the point here is to then
after that my grandfather went into her
nursing home so they gave me his 79
chevette
with handicapped plates and i used to
speed around and this thing i'd i'd
pedal to the metal so the whole thing
was shaken we it had multiple nicknames
one was the golf ball another one was it
was the lunch box you'd get pulled over
the office would be like you handicapped
what's wrong with you like i'm
this is a long time ago like [ __ ] didn't
matter so i would pull up to high school
and i was always late i've never heard a
territory and i was always late and i
would just park in front of my high
school at the fire hydrant and back then
i would just go to school all day and
not give it a thought come outside at
the fire hydrant there was my car no
ticket no nothing and just drive away
yeah the olden times were much
much easier and life was better so again
it's just funny to me to watch the [ __ ]
where you're here in the handicapped
spot it's like you're you're my mini me
pop up the picture of you when you're
young oh my god it's so creepy look just
like me which one please don't not the
i'll post the one the most recent
that one's that's brutal that's brutal
that picture let's keep going there's
absolutely nothing to celebrate when
you're broke under 100k in your bank
account what are you doing out partying
and [ __ ] off dude you got to get back
to work and make some money people hated
this one this one went viral this man
gets zero play okay chris are you
driving a base model audi i'm not taking
your advice that's the one i was talking
about i know
listen this one over so you can go like
a farmer you live like a farmer i'm not
a farmer i know nothing about farming
okay but there was this expression from
the olden days where i'm from where you
would say you know what you act like a
farmer people come and they ask you
where you at i got nothing you know
nothing i have nothing you don't need to
walk to drive around being all flashy
you can that's your choice and and
people fully didn't understand what i
was talking about here because a lot of
the people i see my age all they're
doing all day they're going to the
regular minimum wage job then [ __ ]
off getting drunk blowing their money at
bars on the weekends smoking weed what
are you doing celebrating what are you
out partying for four nights a week six
nights a week a lot of these people
party like almost every night like what
are you doing there's so much more
important [ __ ] to do now while you're 18
and this is the period of time where
it's so easy it's not like easy you got
to put your mind to it but it's so
possible for any more than it's ever
gonna be easier than it exactly it's
easier than it's ever been to make
shitloads of money online no one easier
than it's ever gonna be in your life
even if we were talking 100 years ago
when you're young and you don't have a
spouse and a house and kids and
health problems because you're getting
old and your shit's falling apart like
this is your time you can go out and
accomplish and accomplish and accomplish
and really build something for yourself
i'm with you kid i'm with you and i know
a lot of you are convinced that money
like isn't everything which it's not
money is not everything but money 1 000
makes your life better not in just like
the aspects you think like when you
think money a lot of people think you
know you get to buy fancy cars watches
all that dumb [ __ ] like no dude that is
not what's fun about money at all what's
fun about having money is the freedom to
do whatever you want when you want if i
want to travel next week and go to
europe i can do it i don't have a job
that i'm attached to i can work from
anywhere i can do what i want you can
give back to people you love which is
like the best feeling in the world it's
not even about buying the cool stuff
yeah for me it's always been when i've
had money like making money if i have a
friend that's like jesus christ i don't
know how i'm going to make my rent
i got your rent don't worry about have
fun and when you make money you're
having even more fun i think it's really
fun to help people it's right it really
is yeah it is fun you know it's not just
about getting cars and dumb [ __ ] dude
money makes your life better start
making some i know this is going to hit
the right people who actually listen to
me and take advantage of this and think
damn really maybe i should start making
money and some people are gonna say [ __ ]
this guy i like getting high all the
time drinking with friends and yeah
that's that's gonna be the best days of
my life no make money and enjoy it then
that rules with yourself like when i was
in college i was still having lots of
fun my first semester but i made rules i
would go out once for every thousand
dollars i made you know and then that
fun is even more fun because you're like
damn i earned this if you ever bought me
a 30 000
purse i would be mortified i would be
like you know what this is gross you
know how much we could have helped our
family with this and i i don't want it i
mean i don't want you know don't buy me
a dollar store purse either because
[Laughter]
but really like not truly i'm not being
ridiculous but you know what i mean this
kid's trying to be taped so bad you know
why you think that because i'm young g
five mil generated at 18 financially
free college dropout no wonder people
compare me to that guy i mean and and
just
mild christian modesty it just emanates
from you this humble kid in the
handicapped
so humble god people in tik tok comments
are so stupid you didn't like the cigar
correctly shut up i lit it like a blunt
it smoked it like a g so [ __ ] off all
right calm [ __ ] down he's 18 okay
yeah he shouldn't be smoking cigars but
jesus christ go easy like maybe say uh
you know hey here's how you light a
cigar instead of insulting people don't
talk to your kids that way if you ever
have kids one day you do that right
stupid
okay go inside you're practicing
treating people all right well i want
you to give this kid a final rating one
to ten eleven eleven out of ten that's
the highest rating one yet
that's so awesome it might be partial
all right well thank you guys i'm giving
a hundred dollars to someone who likes
the video and then joins the discord the
get [ __ ] done university we're dropping
next month it'll teach them all my
social media marketing business tips i
have other big people like gabe girl
making the fitness section a bunch of
really cool shit's gonna be inside can i
say something say something so you know
sonny and i were talking about me doing
a section and now i have a lot of varied
life experience that i could bring to
the table but i am curious if anybody
has anything to say what they want to
hear from me in that what should my mom
add to the get [ __ ] done university
bonus content all right guys smell you
[Music]
rather later on the wall won't last long